continuing my top ten of favorite
characters I give you
Doc Holliday from Tombstone and I know
what many of you are thinking come on
that was a real person they didn't make
this guy up he's not a work of fiction
and in my respect yes this guy did
really exist and everything they
technically say about him is true the
Lord knows nobody really knows who
confronted Johnny Ringo in that famous
battle but I think most historians and
even movie goers will recognize this is
a very romanticized version of the Old
West okay not spaghetti western
romanticized but still romanticized and
Doc Holliday might be the most
romanticized character of them all he's
a gun slinging poker playing poetry
quoting elegant badass who lives every
day like it's his last because honestly
it could be his last he had tuberculosis
so his thought was fuck it I'm gonna die
anyway
in fact his theory was he would always
die with his boots on why because he
didn't give a damn what anyone thought
so he was almost certain that he would
die in a gun battle but sure enough at
the very end and after pissing off a
great many deal of people he still died
in a hospital bed in the very end the
joke was on him but the film certainly
played out that he was a very tragic yet
somehow also humorous character he
didn't give a shit about the rural
society the law his morals his ethics is
drinking his sickness he only valued one
thing and that was his friendship to
Wyatt Earp
Wyatt Earp was considered by many people
a good man and certainly one of the best
lawmen who ever lived and the fact that
he would show someone that everybody has
given up on the time of day definitely
meant a lot to Doc
so anything Wyatt wanted to do even if
it was to take down the entire cowboy
gang all across the West you would go
for it
even if it meant teaming up with Merle
from The Walking Dead to do it no
seriously that's Merle every time I saw
Walking Dead I'm like hey that's the guy
from Tombstone Wow but I digress
the Doc Holliday in this version was
probably a little bit more eloquent
romantic than the real was I mean
obviously I never met the guy but from
the descriptions he was a little bit
more hardcore in that you wouldn't hear
quite as much poetry from him
and he wasn't charming 24/7 he could be
a very ruthless drunk just like a lot
drugs can be but that doesn't mean this
character isn't still badass as hell
he's intelligent and wise yet still
walks down that thin line of the law
sometimes a good guy sometimes a bad guy
he just plays it by ear if there was a
person he didn't like he loved pissing
him off he loved playing both the victim
and the predator on top of that he was a
great poker player that much is true too
that means he had a clear understanding
of the human psyche at least when they
were lying to him it takes a great deal
of skill to figure that out and even
more to figure out how to make a profit
on it yeah he was a drunk yeah he had
tons of weaknesses yeah even he wouldn't
make fun of himself all the time for it
remember this scene that was awesome but
all of that was okay because not only
could he put his money where his mouth
was or should I say his gun words mouth
was but he seemed like one of those
people who didn't have many friends but
when he did he held them very close in
fact really in the movie it seems like
he only has two people he can count on
when is his girlfriend which even the
movie seems to exploit as supportive but
also destructive which he would
inevitably leave in the end and the
other two Wyatt Earp which he would
never leave in the end it's constantly
walking that line between sanity and
madness but having that one trait that
he can never turn back on his dedication
to his one true friend and though much
of it is romanticized he still carries a
lot of traits that deserve to be admired
and I am iyer them a great deal I mean
obviously I don't agree with everything
he does but a character who in many ways
loses so much of himself and yet somehow
find so much of himself just in how
dedicated he is to another person I
think that is pretty cool like out of
all the people in the world there's just
that one he respects so friggin much Doc
Holliday in Tombstone is proof of that
half the time you want to smack him the
other half you want to tip your cowboy
hat too
he's an awesome character and I'm proud
to have him in the number nine spot
you